so what's your name my name is Sonia
bison my real name is I changed my name
from a name that my family would not
find me as my father would not give my
name is Levi Bryson Bryson I changed my
last name and my first name my middle
name because you know I don't know I'm
what was your name no son yeh say sir
bye sir
my mother inspired me to be the person I
am but she also very cutely when she get
drunk
call me [ __ ] and stuff but I did
everything my mama asked me even though
certain things she asked me to do I
didn't agree but I still didn't you know
cuz I loved her and she always took care
of me but my god nobody I mean and so
I've been suffering on the streets back
and forth you know Rossi - yeah and the
best thing I do is give him and and it's
not the lien on the streets not a
replacement I love I don't know habit my
psychologist said I go out there so I
get love it's not the love that I'm
getting not getting from my family I'm
not worried about that because I don't
know none of them I mean I also say with
my brothers and my sisters none of them
I turned to drugs because that's now I
have nobody the kids that I do have the
girl he wanted to be with me because I
was a transgender and I was going to
college back that was going to
cosmetology school I was in Uptown I was
trying to make my life better
yeah Chicago and I was home this is
everywhere I just can't
phantom I've won I'm looking for love
but I can't find it I don't know who to
be I don't know what I am no more
sometimes sometimes the day my boy
sometimes cousin I got five children by
this one girl and she's a lazy and she's
bisexual whatever and she's got kids you
know our kids and I love her to death
but she didn't want me to be around the
kids just one is my spine my son you
know
[Music]
okay I went to Johnson elementary school
it when I was in Houston Texas you know
Paris I had my stepdad in mind and my
mother we pretty well
girls use our hunt me and take me that
house that's a steal camera I've started
figure out why I can't run it from I
played football I went to then we moved
back to Chicago my mother finally left
him after the abuse and
my my stepfather used to beat my mother
that's why she spends a lot of time in
this church and in 72 that's what my
mother met this man named elder man he
was a Mormon of we joined the Mormon at
churches it was ain't no was my mother
was a sanctified see with the Mormon I
become a Mormon then we moved to Chicago
I went to heritage middle school where
in the black schools I was held back for
some reason I was in fourth grade for
almost two years when I went they
transferred me to this other it's like I
always school reducing 80s
how was your relationship with your
stuff though I liked him my stepdad
because he's my stepdad II but I kind of
fear them could essentially I felt that
I was protecting my baby sister and my
mother mother from the abuse or let it
be on me instead of him you know
he would put his thing between my legs
because I at that time I was like 4 or 5
years old when I cuz I remember every
day he did - you know he'd make me get
in the bathtub with him he he put his
finger in he'll try his finger my mama
didn't I try to tell her and she said
what he try to tell me and she act like
I was stupid
like I couldn't say nothing so I didn't
ever say nothing I went to school every
day I tried to be the best beauty my
mother brother sister didn't go to
school I wouldn't school every day
because I mean that's my only escape
religion was my escape to try to
outsource it religion try to prove
myself to everybody but myself
and now I've had our aids at school when
would they move when I'm my mother moved
me had me moved to my heritage middle
school she gave me up to this white guy
named Richard Thompson he's my legal
guardian and but you know he was a high
school teacher of the high school I was
getting ready to go - what a treat when
your stepdad was molesting you a between
4 and 12 years old that's a weird time
yeah a very long time
I'm my mother my mother I'm trying to
save her from being abused I figured
everything that happened to me was
happening to me so that wouldn't happen
to my my mother or my sisters you know I
would say better II believe the actions
suffered the punishment because I know
what's going on and my baby sister she's
disarmed baby I didn't want him to try
to mess with her but since I was already
fine pick you know he already put in
spent his ding ding between my legs put
me in the back bed laid on top of me in
you know and made me get in the bathtub
with him my mother my mother never knew
a lick I suffered until one time hidden
in the hip and I was started bleeding
all over the place
he threw a shoe at me because I didn't
want to do what he wanted to do I was
laying on the couch he caught one me to
come getting in the bed I told him I
didn't feel like it
he hit me through the shoe get your
answer and then it hit me in the head
inside the hairy little churches in his
70s got hurt and so he took me to Isis
that's the only way my mother noticed
that she seen the blood on the pillow
she won't even know what happened
but she and but I knew my mother Lou did
my daddy was around he woulda killed her
and him both of them and but I knew my
daddy could not find that my real daddy
will never find out if there whenever us
here
because my mama would drink herself to
death anyway she was doing it anyway she
blamed herself after years of later but
it's just she could have stopped at him
when I was younger you know she didn't
do nothing you know Turner I can use
this guy will friendly family another
guy who is friend of family he picked me
up I was going to the forest reserve I
was cultural forces are look at the
deers and stuff in the suburbs of
Chicago and he picked me up and he was
drain he's a wannabe racer yes you know
my mother always gave me beer and so we
was in the truck he took me all the way
to the corn-fed so wily over here he
starts scratching on me he's gonna date
you know hurting me you know he ripped
my clothes off I had to walk what he did
to me he tried to make me have sex with
him and I'll time I figured out that get
out I jumped out of the truck and ran
down the highway butt-naked I was 12
years old being by that time or 13 and
the police the sheriff took me by my
mother house it was like nothing really
happens you know it's always was a
winter court you know but no one went to
court so what can I do
oh I only person I can love is me and
God loves me I don't care what people
think you know I think what I do because
I enjoy it that's the only pleasure I
get I've seen that satisfied man at
least I made him happy that's like
they'll give me a happiness within
myself you know a little sad action
do you have prettier customers out here
because you're living on Skid Row now
yeah I have customers out here yeah your
regular customers yes sir
yes they do tell me about your regular
customers well he's the one that wanted
me to lick his ass and you know because
I did I did everything well and because
they want you know hey cuz I'm I enjoy
giving it angle say I because this is
another transsexual calls herself super
here and she's trying to ruin and
scandalized my name and I never did
nothing to hurt huge real bad I haven't
even talked to him
when you say lick his ass you mean yeah
rim hits you know but ho yeah so I could
dig he never comes but he'll come by
every hour on the air and pick me up you
do the same thing each time you know I
don't know yeah I mean and then met a
few guys that a hell they just want the
head and get it over then I don't know I
could do it and get it out of the out of
the way and sometimes I do if it tries
to you know what is her drug um Chris
doing caddy Chevy is what
crack crack cocaine I prefer to call it
the the rich person's high but not
enough dream to make fulfill my need it
see crack motivates me in a sexual way
that's most affected I go out in the
street and I have yeah I can do
everything with superb attention or I
can focus on the sexual actually I ain't
got to worry about old feelings of my
past or my my you know childhood and it
puts me it separates me from everyone
you know thing every with all the people
I've become one person you know I don't
know it just makes me a different
individual you know how about you been
using crack and well I started when I
was 19
no 21 but I graduate once I get got out
of school tile exam
my so-called friend her name for Trisha
she graduated me from the crack - he
said she started me on a sticker that's
the what is it supposed to do but all
the times she's baked me once we got up
to the the pipe thing they had bows back
then but that's when I noticed I started
losing weight and getting skinnier and
and then I'm I moved I don't think I was
hooked
you know but then after a while I spend
thousands I was like on the south side
guys that I knew I call them brothers
and they stopped the drug dealers from
selling to me I had to go way harder the
area but there they get mad at the guys
a custom out like that's why y'all doing
it what we tie do you do this no you
gotta get some sleep and I'd be up for
weeks you know and that was right before
my mother passed away I was called my
mother every time I go around my mother
I was getting two fights with her I'm in
company she was aggravated fight and I
didn't you hit my mother you know I
don't care like my uncle my uncle one my
mother's brother brother on my stepdads
brother now he even came to me everyone
at 14 years old - but he had liked him
better than my by then I was already in
to act out the lifestyle of being gay I
don't know if that I chose it or whatnot
but I mean I have a habit like I haven't
ever figured how can I be straight if I
got five children by there's me a girl
do you think you think what happened to
you and you were four to twelve with
your stepdad kind of he's trying to
change your sexuality yes I went to a
therapist when I was young
I want a lot of therapists action why
might this way cuz I thought it was
wrong for me to be me
I'll go to the theater they said well
maybe you're changed by Eternia 18 or 19
and you know this time I doing like
Tessa's like to do the monkeys back in
the ad they do the test is for the like
to give you the shock if you mind good
and I was willing to try cuz I wanted to
be normal but my normal was gone you
know I enjoy doing what I was doing I
enjoy giving pleasure to guys and girls
I've tried the first girl I ever did
something with she gave me gonorrhea in
my truck I was I was at the age of 13
then and I find out when I burn this
girl did me I know that she's the one
that introduced me to crack you think
you're happy right now I'm saying I'm
about the happiest right now than I was
several years ago I was a wreck I was
ready to I said become a serial killer
yeah you know not to other people but to
myself you know my family that was
absolutely after my mother passed away
you know I'm happy that she's passed but
I'm not happy because I know where she
said I know she's resting and no one's
hurting her but also I also know that
she can't make me hurt myself no more
every time I was either trying to hang
myself or take a bunch of Hill consume
station wish I was never born and I
tried to do it think she wanted
everything but I couldn't please it I
went to do some religious you know
you're making better you know just make
my mother knows
exist steady I memorized hit the Bible
the Quran and she just
I'm always [ __ ] always domination
she says she wish I was never born and
what can I do
dear brothers and sisters yeah pretty
much
careful my mother when she get drunk
they taught here so much now she she's
not my mother became later on she did
change their life it's more more of
Muslim Islamic afterwards but I didn't
associate with her no more
ain't so she wouldn't my brothers and
sisters because all my education you
know I got it because I wanted to be one
to get escaped my family name my mother
passed away and I did not make it to her
funeral she cussed me out and I did not
make it to her said she wish I was never
born and Aunty I would have showed I
came I found out my mother was dead a
few years ago I took her some flowers
and I bought her a brick of riches cuz
that's what she drank and when I get
down to the suburbs as you might see
y'all see my mother because she used to
go to the go club early as one she's a
holic you know hands of slugs and stuff
and she always be at the go club early
morning she wasn't near as data out
there and I seen the lady in the store
in the working the dough club I see see
my mama she said do you know your mama
passed away which I never guys she has
to say goodbye so you cut yourself
sometimes I cup I hurt myself because I
don't want to hurt my family
I don't hurt no one it was my mother my
anybody in my family they might say bad
things to me but I've never put my hands
on no one or my family cuz last time I
did I hurt my baby sister to dude I
pushed her to a hole in the floor she
says something about my dad I came in
knowing but she still said him said she
wished my dad you did there's something
like that and I pushed her who's playing
in a band Oh building we shouldn't have
been playing anywhere and she I covered
the hole up and she walked over the
hallways like you're a straight drop to
the floor
but after then I never would hurt no one
not my sister I'm knowing my family the
cutting surgery when they started when
when no one was seeing her nice time
when I was like 14 13 years old 12 years
old well the people used to say I'm
trying to convince I'm not talking
that's suicide me releasing pressure if
I was trying to kill myself I know how
how to cut the van straight up this is
my way of just when I get angry I don't
hurt nobody either hurt myself than
anyone I'm not trying to kill myself I
was trying to kill myself like years ago
I would've I took pills overdoses and me
was knowing you really cared my mom are
you going through another side my but
every time she say something abusive to
me or that she did that I've done
something wrong and I still try to
please her but she still do it you know
and so
but uh my mother and the only let's just
shoot up to shoot up a lot I as you
shoot up is the top speed box and some
three by with my uncle
and that's when uh the help scene came
out you know right nothing bad ain't no
he I was too young
my uncle was older you know and and you
need of there's my stupid mistake but
daddy my uncle used to shoot it for me
you know yeah I've never told my mother
nobody in the family because I asked I
wanted to know how do you do it
you know and shoot up the mm but if I
was being later on when I said chosen
there was this religion it was the
strictly to keep me in line but
something happened that demise where one
of the guys asked me for section and I
figured that was wrong and I said
brother stone ax you don't do that and
when you asked me I figured I figure it
was a setup
good morn finally did I just pretty much
my face it was dwindled about going to
the mask theater whatnot
you know so I've been leave it alone I
go to a Masjid with with transgenders
and lesbians for May for LGBT community
in Chicago you know and it's just on
test I belong I don't go around here no
more because someone put my name out
there I guess it's a good thing they
stopped me from going and I wouldn't go
go now anyway
because I've been reading the crime
people they said why would you deny
someone worship they denied me worship
and even they said God is observing our
worship
then if God's deserving of all worship
why can't I worship Him to give any
friends
yeah it's good name Paula I called my
friend yes he's got a dog named Ariel
and now the dog just takes advantage of
me you've got comes she just jumped up
on me and lick me and tried to make me
in my mouth when I she just tasted man
trust me she'd be humping and everything
you know and that's pretty much I had
just the other person I thought with my
friend he wasn't my friend and I was
about to get into a fight well I didn't
get in the fight I could have fought
back but I wanted to see the reaction of
the person but his name's black and I
said I came around them
right and I couldn't what to do but
what's the name that I wanted to see if
they was going to either help try to
help me or say anything did he say do
not they turned their back so I like
when he came here I just got up and
walked away
use the out of the five I think about
like but I walked away cuz they showed
me right there that they were he wasn't
my friend they wouldn't my friend Amy
saying that they turned his face that's
why I walked away all right thank you no
thank you so much for talking to me no
problem
with with everything well I'm trying to
get it together my unit ready I'm
probably don't try to go to rehab
maybe after get some cigarettes but I I
got go to rehab I mean I don't know what
else to do doesn't make my life better
you know I don't know how to live and if
I could find the right guidance I'm
already lost yeah I believe I have
angels that tout and people see me
talking as I talk to angels yes yeah
they're my friends and they listen to me
alright well thank you talk to me
you